o fofo contra kaká o treinar pra cá
brinca
logo que vai provar isso dentro por
favor que a igreja em que a gente no
campeonato com vocês é que todo esse
barulho aqui citando que o mercado está
ligada não vou desligar não vou ligar
porque não falou no patamar foi o que eu
sempre mesmo que o fixo ado cara fica
toda orgulhosa
agora quem sabe a causa da paz há dois
pastel que vai ser o tema do vídeo ilha
só fala sobre a coca cola incluindo se
faz um vídeo da própria escola com isso
tem que falar sobre a copa col espalhou
rápido da copa col não vou falar sobre
qual não vou falar sobre rádio cope
porque eu não quero diabo só falam de
rápido ele fica reclamando de kinder ovo
é caro pronto aí a coca-cola novo túnel
ou cada um uma surpresa quando eu compro
cópia qual aprendeu que aqui terei um
cachorro um tempero de mim hoje dentro
da copa um tempero e mil o meu deus o
cara que ia fazer qualquer instantânea
mas o que eu não quero falar disso não
vou falar disso tem gente está sofrendo
por causa disso tem gente que tá aí
lutando contra a copa pra poder para
conseguir seu direito tem gente ficar
doente caso isto não quero falar disso o
seu a copa foi gente agora na garotada
de boquim no facebook dá uma olhada em
paz o que lá estava eu na rodada naquela
página 100 sobre a ideia da eutanásia na
publicação e tal action futebol sei lá
eu fui aos comentários essa foto para
todos praticamente todos os comentários
eram assim chuva nita annie tem uma
merda deus ea nossa rainha isso que a
diva nyaneka a mostra me vem na cabeça
se eu pego diz tanto assim gente porque
que a mim o fox news e lembra da nitro
eu não sou fã de anita não sou fã do meu
senhor é um mito tescaro fica o tecido
quando as pessoas é odeiam as pessoas
gratuitamente não gosto de gente
fica procurando coisas ao diário queria
saber o que essa mulher fez o que é que
a nita fez pra todo mundo onde ela vai
ter um pai me falasse não mas você não
viu o vídeo que ela destratou fãs e
chamou o cara de pobre o cara de mal
educado a pessoa que já foi pobre uma
vez na vida não respeita uma pessoa no
seu que ela ficou rico e esqueceu a
humildade ela ficou rico esqueceu a
humildade ela perdeu a humildade ela
perdeu um estudante olha você está me
assistindo agora eu tenho um veículo de
comunicação muito bom que o youtube tem
muitas pessoas que mexe e eu quero
passar isso para você agora agora nesse
momento
agora o que é que a humildade pra você
foi a humildade não é curtir foto
ninguém não é você se ninguém mudar não
é você deixar que as pessoas fiz na sua
cabeça não é você deixar que as pessoas
de um milhão não é você que está sendo
falso fingido que falei com qualquer
situação você ser humilde é uma pessoa
chegar na porta de sua casa e falar se o
almoço eu tô com fome sem a vontade de
comidas e pega essa pessoa se traz para
sua casa se foca na sua mesa para comer
com você
humildade você está a um menor com você
como se fosse igual ou maior que fosse
você ouviu não se deixar a pessoa joga
latina é um cara pessoa que a pessoa
normal ela vai najma e precisava
humilhar o cara precisa família [ __ ]
[ __ ] você tá no seu ambiente de
trabalho imagine a pessoa que viaja o
brasil inteiro fazendo show aí vem um
cara do mal educado e jogou uma lata e
veja só no vídeo que não foi uma foi do
arquivo quer ver o cara não consegue da
primeira vez em que chama mais atenção
na segunda mas mesmo assim
precisava ter falado aquele monte de
coisa agora deixa eu me jogava lá tinha
do vídeo guitarra latina você vai dizer
sim nossa uma latinha que fofocar jogam
a outra por favor lógico que não quer
que vai fazer isso vai acontecer e você
vai falar merda o cara que foi o que ela
fez não pára de falar mal da mulher só
que o fcs aqui no brasil é assim alguém
fez sucesso fora d água ea cartão para
de onde anita cara pode ficar o dia das
pessoas sem motivo nenhum para de olhar
é que eu tô ligado que você tá na balada
top show das poderosas e vai dançar cara
se você tiver se divertindo os seus
amigos você tiver aquela magnífica e
tocar uma música da minha que você dizer
para ele pensar no tempo ou a letra não
ser muito [ __ ] para deixar se
divertir você deixar de curtir com os
seus amigos por causa de um box de um
preconceito musical é uma boa história
não curto funk eu também não sou fã de
uma banda de rock
eu só fiquei por ter sido com as pessoas
que continha uma coisa sim nica fico por
tipo raúl castro está ligado para o
carro aquele cara que todas as meninas
button é quem goste minha vida nem como
ficou eu poderia ficar no poder e onde a
escala poderia sair comentando as fotos
na internet ou por que todos os meninos
vamos ficar só porque ele é rico e
famoso ô ô ô ô hebreu poderia hoje estar
poderia arriscar porque não tem uma fama
que ele tem um dinheiro que ele tem mas
eu não conheço esse cara tudo trocar uma
idéia com ele eu vou dizer a ele porque
há quem até porque eu tenho visto muito
na internet a gente criticando a volta
de rebelde eu vejo muita gente fala ai
meu deus quando penso que a bosta acabou
e na volta eu não sei porquê que bota
gente de pedir 20 anos vestindo roupa de
15 dizendo que rebelde aí eu deus se
fazer uma bandinha de escola e enfrentar
o diretor rebelde eu sou um terrorista
olha vou dizer pra você logo desde o
início uma coisa eu não gasto o meu
botão de ligar a televisão pra assistir
rebelde porque eu não gosto num
não é minha praia agora eu vou dia
rebelde porque você tem que aprender uma
coisa tudo que eu falo aqui é para que
vocês não se torne as pessoas edícula no
futuro eu sei que muita gente de 14 de
13 anos que me assiste mas eu quero
passar uma coisa boa para você se você
não gosta de uma coisa se você não gosta
de uma coisa não é porque ela não presta
é porque eu não é pra você deixar
explicado de hoje e deixou mais chegar
pra você para você entender você não
pode chegar uma criança está sem dor
aventureira e fala para ela assim o
menino ei tu eitas indoor porque em imbé
silva acha que tomar chá de água de
unicórnio
acho que vai poder falar em inglês que é
isso aí um rapaz de apoio a gente vai
assistir no browser mas isso deve ou meu
deus do céu vai atingir o tamanho do
zodíaco que a cultura não pode ser só
porque porque não é pra você porque dora
a aventureira é pra criança então sabe a
novela rebelde que você odeia não é pra
você
veja bem o que se passa na novela
rebelde são adolescentes que são
rebeldes
eles querem fazer coisas que os pais
proibiram eles querem quebrar as regras
eles querem fazer coisas dos painéis não
deixa esquecer os maiorais porque é isso
que a maioria dos adolescentes bloco
entendeu não é pra você é para esse tipo
de pessoa e se você não goste você não
curte eu vou apresentar pra você um
produto revolucionário o melhor produto
para você que o the rebel com este
produto você vai poder fazer uma coisa
maravilhosa que é mudar de canal
você também vai poder desligar a
televisão
esse é o sensacional controle remoto só
deixar bem claro que eu não sou fã de
rebelde
eu fique com tecido quando vejo esse
pessoal de ana as coisas sem sentido
então essa é a mensagem este vídeo não
odeia as coisas não fica que tome as
pessoas do funk não fico tentando
humilhar não fica tentando milhares de
pessoas que hurd rebeldes se as pessoas
gostam de rebelde e deixa as pessoas
gostarem revela de cada vez crescer
elas vão mudar isso vai influenciar na
vida seu princípio já dão super mario
nem por isso eu saio por aí para bater a
cabeça na parede podem se sair um real
se você gostou de serviço civil ele foi
útil para alguma coisa você clica aqui e
gostei da eu quero que você deixe a sua
opinião sobre isso que eu falei aqui nos
comentários você não está inscrito neste
canal você pode clicar aqui embaixo
inscrever-se toda vez que tiver um vídeo
novo você vai saber eu queria dizer que
vocês curtir a minha página oficial no
facebook e muita gente sai por aí o
quanto paga para ter o perfil então tá
aqui embaixo a descrição do vídeo então
é isso aí muito obrigado por você teste
desse vídeo até aqui e falou